[Music]
as of January 2018 anyone over the age
of 21 can walk into a store in
California and pick up some marijuana
all you need is some cash or a credit
card to learn more about how legalized
recreational cannabis sales work we
tracked a product up the supply chain
from seed to sale we talked to cannabis
entrepreneurs along the way to find out
what's changed for them operating in a
legal state market and what we found was
surprising excitement yes but also
anxiety about the future of the legal
market under California's highly
regulated and highly taxed system and
industry insiders told us that if the
legal market remains so overtaxed and
over-regulated the black market will
continue to stay in business the story
ends with the sale of the Kiva bar the
product of a company run by a husband
and wife team who began working out of
their Oakland kitchen but let's start at
the beginning about 100 miles away at
Riverview farms which two years ago
converted from poinsettias to pot it's
been a family-owned business for 20
years with daughter Michele Hackett
currently serving as president this is
the agricultural capital of the world
fresh vegetables come out of this
growing region we also have great Pinot
Noir grapes coming out of this region
there's no reason why cannabis shouldn't
be cultivated here Hackett is excited
for the future of the market but under
immense pressure from the increased
regulation and taxation that kicked in
at the beginning of the year Riverview
holds 16 separate cultivation licenses
to grow this amount of cannabis as well
as to distribution licenses to transport
medical and recreational cannabis to
retailers and manufacturers they pay a
harvest tax of $9.25 per dry-weight
ounce of cannabis flower that enters the
commercial market Paquette says that
compliance costs have driven up prices
across the state
I think it's greed people are looking
for a handout and are thinking that
we're weed people we must be waking all
this money but really we're running this
like a farm or
another agricultural operation in the
same community wanting to be treated the
same the greenhouses here hold plants at
all stages of development culminating in
mature plants ready for harvest every
two to four weeks then workers hang the
cannabis to dry before it's ready to be
cut and sent to market but Hackett says
that while business was booming in the
era of medical cannabis legalization
strict licensure requirements have
shrunk her customer base significantly
since recreational legalization went
into effect we have to protect our
license so the only business we want to
do is with other licensed retailers
distributors delivery services in the
past you had a customer list of save
maybe three hundred right now maybe
you're working with 50 it's the green
boom and people are wanting to jump on
the bandwagon and see if they can profit
from this industry but I think what
people will realize is that it takes a
lot of work our next stop is Kiva's
manufacturing facility in oakland a
chocolate factory with one extra
ingredient people want a product they
can trust and rely on and so in the sort
of gray market of California we were
really able to stand out by producing
something that was clean and consistent
every single time edible marijuana has
provoked media stories of
hospitalizations and meltdowns with New
York Times columnist Maureen Dowd once
penning a column about the time she ate
cannabis infused chocolate and freaked
out in a Colorado hotel room shortly
after a legalization but Kiva bars are
hand packaged in two distinctive
wrappers that foreground the
psychoactive THC content in big bold
numbers so that users know exactly how
much they're consuming with each bite
the packaging and labeling on kefir
products is extremely important we treat
every package essentially like a
billboard the education process around
cannabis and consumers learning dosing
it's going to take a while until people
have the same familiarity with cannabis
dosing as they do with alcohol
example Knobloch Palmer says that
although the customer base for marijuana
has increased tenfold since recreational
legalization that the increased taxes
and regulation have forced the company
to make layoffs in recent months the
situation of the market right now is
pretty dire right now there's some a few
hundred licenses in 2017 there were
maybe twenty to thirty thousand
operators so we've seen a significant
drop in the number of people allowed to
operate in the market taxes are a big
component of the new market there are
essentially four times that the cannabis
is taxed it's surprising that with the
legal market in California that
companies are experiencing less volume
and less demand and that has everything
to do with the cost of cannabis the
price of cannabis to the end consumer
our company has unfortunately had to do
a layoff
for the first time in our company's
history we were all really excited and
kind of promised a really healthy robust
cannabis marketplace we're all sort of
hanging on for our lives
not luck Palmer says she's still
optimistic about the future of the
industry but that some major reforms
still need to happen in order for a
legal market to out-compete the black
market the end consumer is walking into
a regulated store and seeing prices up
here and then they're walking into an
unregulated store or they're calling
their guy and they're seeing prices down
here so the unregulated market really
has the potential to derail the entire
system because it's undercutting all the
legal operators at every opportunity our
next stop is at farm labs a testing
facility in Long Beach before legal weed
makes it to market in California the new
law requires testing for purity and
potency often several times that the
cannabis is part of a manufactured
product it's one of many cannabis labs
that existed long before the state
required testing since many companies
such as Kiva underwent voluntary testing
as a way to set their products apart
from the competition
the states don't have enough resources
to provide testing services I think
we're really filling a gap these labs
that have been here from the beginning
dr. Robert brodnik is the research
director at this lab and has a
background in counter narcotics at the
Department of Defense
he says his mind changed when he saw
that cannabis could be a less harmful
alternative to other drugs cannabis is a
potential way to mitigate or offset some
of the the dangers of abuse this view is
in stark contrast to that of Attorney
General Jeff Sessions who buys into the
marijuana as gateway drug argument
heroin addiction starts with
prescription we think a lot of this is
starting with marijuana and other drugs
too studies are still limited but
preliminary data do show that states
with legal marijuana tend to have lower
rates of opioid addiction and overdose
deaths and while testing should make
cannabis products even safer for
consumers Magda worries that
California's testing standards are a
little too stringent I think it's gonna
be a rough start for California with the
amount of products that are they're
gonna fail the pesticide thresholds are
very stringent here cannabis is the most
tested agricultural commodity at this
point for
or California cannabis industry to be
successful there needs to be kind of a
middle ground the final destination is
of course the storefront known for years
in California as the dispensary we
visited a green alternative in San Diego
just minutes from the border and
ironically down the road from the Drug
Enforcement Administration offices the
store counts Kiva as one of its top
sellers and owner Zachary Lazarus says
he's seen a definite spike in sales post
recreational legalization the difference
between operating medicinally versus
recreationally is you have a plethora of
people that have come out the woodwork
that have come out of the closet that
are so happy to be able to consume
cannabis cannabis for the first time or
to relook at it since their college or
high school days but like the other
business owners we spoke with he said
regulations are still too tight taxes
too high and worries that local
governments are too involved in picking
winners and losers in the market with
the licensing system it seems like
there's a lot of barriers to entry right
now but that doesn't have to be that way
yes we need strict compliance so we need
accountability but we also need to give
all those mom-and-pop shop owners an
opportunity a chance to give back with
taxation a chance to grow jobs and a
chance that really contribute to the
cannabis community and like everyone in
the cannabis industry Lazarus still
lives under the dark cloud of federal
prohibition stores like his still have
trouble even opening bank accounts we
don't have a fair shake when it comes to
being able to transact and do it
aboveboard like everybody else issues
with the banking system and fear of
federal crackdowns were a consistent
theme every step of the way
it's scary I'm not gonna lie it's a huge
issue for us in terms of banking having
us federally legal would take a huge
weight off my shoulder canvas being
illegal at the federal level is
certainly a challenge that the industry
thinks about on a daily basis it's a
natural governor to the growth potential
of the industry the words coming out of
Jeff Sessions mouth
to me is like the words coming out of an
slingers mouth back in the 1930s you
have a lot of criticism and you have a
lot of ignorance that really doesn't
understand an industry when you don't
understand something you tend to
criticize it but despite lingering
uncertainty everyone along the supply
chain remained optimistic that there
will be regulatory reforms in California
an eventual legalization nationwide the
cats out of the bag more people in this
country live in a state with some type
of cannabis regulation now so I really
feel there's no going back it's not
going away
so they might as well regulate it and
capitalize on the tax money the whole
state really wants this it was 37 and a
half million people in our state you
really can't go backwards I mean that's
just reality
California is going to a recreational
market is a huge win for the industry
for the cannabis plant overall it will
really help cannabis become more
mainstream allow more people to have
access to it and really further the
movement in a way that we probably have
never seen before
[Music]